so in november i was mindlessly
scrolling on twitter and i saw somebody
uh chirp at you and say are you calling
the top and you responded it was october
18th by the way and you said yes and i
said to myself they better hope to god
he's wrong because he'll never let them
forget so by the way it wasn't a random
person this is it was ari levy of cnbc
yeah so it was a pretty well known
journalist
and i think it was the day of the top it
was exactly the day
it was off by a couple hours so uh
they have not forgotten because they
keep bringing it up um describe why you
thought it was that and a lot of it i
think came from the 2000 uh kind of
bubble bursting and kind of what the
historical overlay was so yeah i mean
2000 a lot of people had this view
including a lot of my colleagues at
founders fund that have been um
let's say cracking a whip on recently um
that things just go up and to the right
and then it's only a question of time
like every company will be worth more
money or more value over time whether it
takes one year two years three years or
five years so that you could pay any
price for an investment let's say
because eventually you'll grow into that
and that's lodging
over the last 18 months peter and i
particularly internally were like this
market is going to collapse here's why
blah blah blah so internally we've been
debating this uh pretty consistently uh
with with incredible clarity both peter
and i argued this at an off site last
summer
and then strongly argued like about a
week before so one of the reasons why
one already asked we had done we
conducted an offsite in san francisco
about a week or two before and i've made
strong case internally that we should
stop investing period like there's
nothing that's priced appropriately so
my brain had been chewing on this it
wasn't kind of a random response
that said the lesson of 2000 was you
know things that go this way also go
this way and this specific reason things
clapped in 2000 was the federal reserve
raised interest rates six times from mid
1999 to early 2000 and what that did was
it caused technology stocks to collapse
collapsed by 90 percent so it's like
well guess what if the fed raises
interest rates six times technology
stocks are going to collapse by 90 this
is like a law of physics we had actually
used this slide a version of this slide
which i've actually tweeted recently in
our lp presentation a founder's fund the
last two years so we've been internally
talking to our lps saying eventually
interest rates have to go up when
interest rates go up technology stocks
will go down yeah we can talk about why
that is but it is actually inevitable
and so
when the the reason why that specific
timing came to be is
for a long time many people myself
included have been talking about
publicly jack dorsey et cetera that
we've been going through inflation in
the united states um i started tweeting
about inflation in january 2022
and uh oh sorry yeah so maybe actually
21. but yeah 21. sorry getting the years
confused
and but everybody was the government the
the current administration and their you
know sort of supporters were in denial
about that were inflation and they were
suffering inflation there's all these
excuses it's like transitory blah blah
blah you should see the reaction to my
tweet about we're in real inflation and
everybody's like transitory like no it's
not transitory that's the stupidest
thing ever um but
basically all the excuses were starting
to decay over the last year and by
october even the transitory people like
ran out of logic to argue that it was
transitory so i was like basically
what's going to happen is eventually
when the excuses go away
the fed and everybody else is going to
realize we have actual inflation when
they have actual inflation the
technology stocks will start going down
and so that's basically what happened so
when one there was one press conference
i think the white house press secretary
basically gave up on the transitory line
i was like okay all hell's gonna break
loose and that was right around then and
that's why i was like okay well you
don't have to discount the probability
that people figure this out anymore